SPEAKER 1: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
My name is [INAUDIBLE],, and
I will be your moderator
for today's webcast on
maximizing microservices,
managing complexity,
and extending value
with Apigee and Istio.
A few housekeeping tips--
you can find links
to the references
made during this
webcast on the Resource
console of your screen.
If you have any
questions, please
feel free to post them
anytime in the QA council.
You don't have to wait till
the end of the session.
So please feel to post them
in as soon as you have them.
Also, we will be
recording this webinar,
and it will be e-mailed to all
the registrants of the webinar.
In today's session, we will
talk about the essentials
of maximizing your
microservices strategy.
We will plan for a very
practitioner-heavy session.
We have two demos
that will demonstrate
how we are working to help you
manage complexity and extend
value of your microservices
with Apigee and Istio.
With that said, I would
like to welcome our speakers
for today's session--
Nanden Sridhar, product
manager at Google Cloud
and Scott Ganyo, software
engineer at Google Cloud.
Nanden has over 14
years of IT experience
in financial services enterprise
architecture, software
development, and IT
consulting and has
been multiple roles of an
architect designer, mentor,
and technical specialist.
He currently helps customers
design beautiful APIs
through Apigee Edge and
is deeply interested
in the spaces of API
security and microservices.
Scott Ganyo is a prolific
software developer
with over 25 years
of hands-on expertise
in development, architecture,
resource, and leadership
and is very passionate
about microservices again.
With that said, welcome
to both speakers,
and I would like to now
hand it over to Nanden.
NANDEN SRIDHAR: Thank
you so much, Vijay.
Appreciate the introduction.
Thank you all for taking
time to attend this webinar.
So I'll give you
a brief overview
of what you should expect
from today's session.
We're going to talk about the
concept of service meshes.
What is a service mesh?
Why you think it's even there?
What is Istio, the value
proposition for Istio,
how does Istio solve
the problem, and then
we'll have a demo of Istio.
Right, after that,
we're going to take
a look at API management as
it relates to microservices.
How does service management
and API management coexist,
complement, or are
they the same thing?
And lastly, we're going to take
a look at how Apigee integrates
with Istio, and then we'll
have a demo for that as well.
So without further ado,
let's go dig into this
and see what is a service mesh.
But a lot of enterprises either
considering or have already
started building
new services using
a microservices architecture.
And we all know that
microservices are awesome.
But why is that the case?
What was wrong with
the previous mechanism?
Well, this would be a
fairly good generalization
of a monolithic architecture.
We've got some users.
The front end business logic
is in a monolithic application
that connects to one
or more databases.
Now this architecture
does has some advantages.
You can then have a very
complex application,
those work just fine.
It was easy from a
production point of view,
easy to troubleshoot.
If you had latency issues, you
know exactly where to look.
It's that one
monolithic application.
And if you had to
deploy something,
you just deployed that
app, and you're done.
But there are some
disadvantages to it as well.
[INAUDIBLE] severely
impeded agility,
especially as that application
became more complex.
The front team may be
making some changes.
The back end team may
be making changes.
Every change required to
test that entire monolithic
application.
This is definitely a problem
and increased the ownership cost
for that application.
And so we know
that microservices
solve that problem.
So microservices
started decomposing
this monolithic
application, started
to decompose this
monolithic application
into independent units
functional units,
so that development
teams could operate
on those functional services
independent of each other.
So in this example, that
monolithic application
was split into an invoicing
microservice, a front end
microservice, a NoSQL
DB cluster, and so on.
And so if I were making changes
to the invoicing application,
I didn't have to involve
the front end team,
I could make those changes
and integrate much faster
without involving other teams.
There are also some
interesting byproducts
from this architecture not
just related to agility.
The first is that we could
use the right programming
language for our microservices.
The front end team could
use JavaScript NodeJS.
The invoicing team could use
Springboot, .net, or something.
And they really didn't have--
didn't need to have
much in common.
The second thing is that
as one microservices called
another microservices, i.e.
when they transferred
responsibility
from one microservices
to the other,
they did it over the network.
So a very common
pattern would be
that the invoicing microservices
exposed its interface as an API
over HTTP, and the front
end application didn't
have to know how it was
implemented, by whom it was
implemented, or anything as long
as that contact was maintained
[INAUDIBLE] the front end
application could invoke
the invoicing application.
So this definitely
promoted agility.
It could introduce
changes much quicker.
And this is definitely
a huge benefit
from the microservices
architecture.
Since people started adopting
more of these microservices,
they started making
them more fine-grained.
And before you know,
your architecture
ends up looking like this
because the more fine grained
you make it, the
more you can iterate
on one of those
individual microservices.
Now this on the face of it
can look pretty daunting.
So what you're seeing
here is a network
of microservices that
make up one or more
monolithic applications.
This network of microservices
is what we call a service mesh.
And as you can tell
us, as you build
more and more
microservices, this network
can become massive and complex.
And this complexity becomes
very difficult to manage
and understand.
If you put yourselves in the
shoes of a production operator
managing this sort of a
microservices architecture
and you had a performance
problem to identify,
it's going to be pretty
difficult to identify which
microservice actually was
causing the performance issue
because there are
so many services
running all at the same time.
Another issue is with
introducing agility
while keeping your risk low.
If the invoicing team is quickly
trading and making changes,
what if it breaks?
What if it pushed an inaccurate
change that broke a contract,
and now it causes a
cascading effect of breaking
other microservices?
And there's a third issue.
What about governance?
You have many teams
developing microservices
using programming
and platform choices
that they want to make
that's best suited
for the microservice.
But then how does
a security admin
guarantee that
they're all adopting
best practices of security?
How do you know that
they're all adopting
the right standards for logging,
tracing, and everything else?
So there is a
governance issue now.
So we identified three
interesting things, right?
How do you observe?
The second is how do you
do operational agility
without introducing
more risk, and third,
how do you do a uniform
security from this?
It's easy for one to think that
microservices are, in fact,
terrible.
Monolithic programs
didn't have this problem.
Well, obviously, that's
not the right answer.
Microservices are
perfectly fine.
Yes, these three are
an issue, and this
is exactly why Istio exists.
Istio is an open
services platform
to manage your service
interactions on containers
and VM-based workloads.
That second part
is super important.
It's also for
VM-based workloads.
And I mentioned
service interactions.
That's exactly what
a service mesh is--
managing the interactions
of your network
of your microservices
is what Istio does.
What do I mean by management?
And that's what we'll
dig deeper into as we
get into what Istio does.
So it still solves the
three problems I [INAUDIBLE]
earlier when you're
dealing with microservices.
Gives you observability.
Second, you can have
operational agility, i.e.
the ability to introduce
changes quickly into your system
without introducing
additional risk.
And third, you can introduce
policies for security
without having to depend
on individual teams
to adopt those policies.
You can, as an
enterprise standard,
apply broad security
rules and not
expect individual teams to apply
them on every microservice.
So this is a quick
value proposition
for what Istio does.
Now what we're going to look
at is to see how Istio does it.
The basic architecture construct
for Istio looks like this.
At this point, I'll introduce
the concept of a [INAUDIBLE]..
Now you'll see here I've
got the services A and B,
and both have a proxy
associated with it.
That proxy is what we
refer to as a sidecar.
A quick definition here
of what a sidecar is--
a sidecar is a process that
assists a parent process where
the parent process can transfer
responsibility to the sidecar.
So in this case, service A is
a microservice I've written.
And instead of the microservice
or the microservice developer
implementing every
bit of the [INAUDIBLE]
the microservice
developer implementing
every bit of the architecture,
the microservice developer
is offloading certain
responsibilities
to the proxy, the sidecar proxy.
Now you must assume as
if the sidecar proxy
is part of your application.
If the sidecar proxy is on
your microservices [INAUDIBLE],,
it really is a one
to one mapping.
And most of the times,
they share a kernel
if you're putting it on VMs.
And if not on VMs,
they're in the same pod
if it's Kubernetes.
So for all practical
purposes, that sidecar proxy
is part of your application.
That microservices team must
treat that sidecar proxy
as if it were part
of that microservice.
It is only then can you
rely on the sidecar proxy
to do certain or take up
certain responsibilities instead
of the individual
microservice doing it.
So what responsibilities can
I delegate to the sidecar?
So first off, there
are two things
that a microservice
does very often.
It invokes other
microservices, or it
gets invoked by other services.
So these are easily broken
down into two aspects--
ingress or an egress.
Service A calls other
services or other services
call service A.
What happens with Istio is that
the sidecar proxy intercepts
all ingress or outbound and all
ingress or all inbound traffic
to the microservice.
So the microservice
itself is never
directly accessible without
going through the sidecar
proxy.
And this is a fundamental point.
When you have the
sidecar proxy associated
with every one of your
services, you quickly
realize that all
your network traffic
is happening between
two sidecars,
never happens between the
applications themselves.
And this is a fundamental
point to understand
as to how Istio operates and how
it is able to achieve the value
propositions we talked about--
i.e. observability, agility,
and security.
So now that have established
that all inbound and outbound
services go through
the sidecar, we
will now start talking about
what is we do and how we do it.
So assisting the sidecar
are three components.
I'm going to briefly
touch upon them now,
but we are still going
to have a slide that
explains individually
what these components do.
The first is pilot.
Pilot helps with
service discovery.
I have a [INAUDIBLE],, and
we'll talk about it then.
And the second is a policy
decision point, which is mixer.
It enforces policies
in the service smash.
And unfortunately, you
can't see the cycle here,
but the last one is citadel.
Citadel will help with security.
Citadel is a [INAUDIBLE]
certificate authority
so you can achieve
mutual [INAUDIBLE]
between your service.
Let's start with security first.
So we have established
the basic premise
that there is a sidecar in
front of all your microservices,
and that sidecar has some
delegated responsibilities.
Let's start with security.
How does security
happen with Istio?
There are three
important security points
that Istio provides.
The first is
enabling mutual TLS.
That is authentication
and encryption
between your services.
And this is a very
fundamental point.
Individual applications no
longer have to implement TLS.
[INAUDIBLE]
microservice in service
A [INAUDIBLE]
microservice service
B need to have absolutely no
knowledge of how to do TLS.
That responsibility
of negotiating TLS
is offloaded to [INAUDIBLE]
or the sidecar proxy.
By doing this, I have now
implemented a standard way
of achieving TLS
regardless of whether it's
a database, regardless whether
it's a document application
or a Java application.
That is one way to do mTLS, and
that's still using the sidecar.
The second is to
authorize access
based on service identity,
another crucial and critical
point.
And I have a slide about
it, but I'll catch up to.
The sidecar-- or in
Istio, every microservice
has a service identity.
And we'll come to
that in a second.
And then I can apply
authorization rules
on those services.
So for example, I can say
that only service A can access
service B and no other service.
That is achievable
because we identify
the workload of the service
with an identity, a service
identity.
And that can be used
to apply authorization.
Lastly, you can also apply some
very fine-grained RPC controls.
For example, I want to allow
service A to access service B,
but it can only access
the get operations
and nothing else for only the
post operations and nothing
else.
And so it can also be a very
fine grained organization.
So let's take a quick look
at what these options mean
in detail.
So of course, mutual TLS
is a very standard practice
for securing communication
between two services.
Mutual TLS, we all
use it for encryption
of messages in transit.
But there's some more
we can do with this.
What Istio provides
is this ability
called a strong authentication.
And I touched upon
it briefly before.
Istio provides the ability
to create a service identity.
Now how do we do this?
So there is a standard
called Spiffe, S-P-I-F-F-E,
for those of you
who are interested.
And Citadel is a
certificate authority
that is responsible for signing
certificates in the standard.
So when service A is
brought up, service A
gets a unique service identity.
No other service can pretend
to be service A. I can uniquely
identify service A, and
this is extremely useful
to authenticate that my
service is, in fact, coming
from service A and
not someone else.
So it's easy for me to have
a rule in service B to say,
I will only access communication
from service A. In order for me
to do that, I must have
a strong way of achieving
the identity that is
service A, and this
is done through
Spiffe-based certificate.
A second very critical point
is how these certificates
are automatically rotated.
So every 30 minutes in Istio,
a new T and cert [INAUDIBLE]
is generated, and this new NT
cert is issued to service A.
And these certificates
keep rotating.
In my past life, I
remember we struggled a lot
when it came to
certificate upgrades
with these giant
monolithic applications
with the Java key
stores and everything.
We took, developers, at times,
down time to [INAUDIBLE]
upgrade these certificates.
That would be a
thing of the past
when you use Istio
because certificates
are rotated all the time every
30 minutes and automatically.
The second component I want
to introduce here is mixer.
Mixer is that
extensibility point
that allows you to make
policy decisions in Istio.
Mixer integrates with Apigee.
Mixer integrates
with Stackdriver.
Mixer integrates with Prometheus
and [INAUDIBLE] and all
these other systems.
So Mixer has two main goals.
The first is that it collects
telemetry information
from the Istio architecture.
We talked about how
there's a sidecar in front
of every application.
This presents us with some very
interesting options in addition
to mTLS.
These sidecars can
emit events every time
there's an ingress or an egress.
Those events can be captured
by centralized systems
to produce placing information,
monitoring information,
so you get observability
without changing
any of your applications
regardless of the code
that's written in.
Mixer is that centralized
case that the telemetry events
are selected.
But Mixer also has
another role to play.
Mixer is a policy
decision point.
This is where you can
hold your authorization
rules to say I want only
service A to access B,
or I want service A to only have
read access to B, and so on.
These are authorization rules
or policy decision rules
that I can encode into mixer,
and those decisions are then
enforced by the sidecar.
So mixer provides
that extensibility
to add those custom
rules into Istio.
The last and final
component here is Pilot.
Pilot is responsible for
configuring the plane.
So Pilot has two jobs.
One is providing service
discovery information
when you have a new
service that is registered.
Pilot knows about it and lets
the sidecars know about it.
And second, if
you're doing things
like [INAUDIBLE] releases, AB
testing, all of these rules
are floated into Pilot, and
Pilot pushes that information
to service A.
So in this case, if I had
a new version of service B
and I want to send 20% of my
traffic to this new service,
then here is an example of a
YAML file of how I could do it.
80% of my traffic goes
to the existing service,
20% goes to my new service.
And this is a very
critical point
in maintaining
operational agility.
Right, we talked
about two things.
We talked about observability.
We talked about security.
And this is the third one.
This is how we introduced
operational agility.
This allows development
teams to iterate
very fast because when you
do introduce a new version,
you don't have to use
100% of your traffic
to this new version.
You could start with 5%,
test if there are errors,
and if there are errors,
easily switch back
to the previous version.
If there are no errors,
continue to increase traffic
to this newer version.
What does Istio do in summary?
The value proposition for Istio
is that managing microservices
can be complicated.
It presents a challenge
to production operators
of how to get observability,
how to introduce
operational agility
without increasing risk,
and third, how to do
policy-driven security
so you're not depending on
individual teams to do it.
And Istio addresses
these concerns
on behalf of the application
or the microservices provider
by baking these features into
the basic infrastructures.
Istio can do the routing,
Istio can do the security,
and Istio can introduce
the observability
for what is happening
in your infrastructure.
So at this point, what
they're going to do is
I'm going to get
my colleague Scott.
Scott Ganyo is going to
do a quick demo of Istio
and is going to show
you how Istio works.
SCOTT GANYO: Thank you, Nanden.
What I've put together here is--
it's a storefront.
So I'm going to operate now
at this point as the operator
of my store here, and I'm pretty
satisfied with what I've got.
I can go in and buy a
typewriter, edit my cart,
view the cart.
I've got all of the
standard capabilities
that you would expect
in the storefront.
Now this whole thing
has been created
as a series of microservices.
Now all of this is actually
deployed in a Kubernetes
environment, and each
of these services
is developed in different
style, different language.
We have everything
from Python to Java
to Go represented here as
well as database information
and accessing external
services as well.
So the issue here, then, of
course, as Nandan talked about,
is how do we manage all of this.
Well, the first thing
I wanted to show you
is very simple thing but
a very powerful thing,
and that is being able to
route that information as
like a Canary-type
implementation.
And so Nanden showed you
a version of the YAML.
This is a slightly
different version.
And my shop is a lot of gray.
That's my color.
But I've heard now that
blue is the hip color.
And so what I've done
is I've rolled out
or I've deployed a
version of my app
that takes into account
the fact that I've
heard that people like blue.
So what you see here is I've
change the virtual service,
and I've set up a destination.
So subsets of 80% of
the requests go to gray,
and 20% go to blue.
So once I apply that--
so we're configured now.
Now whenever we go through here,
you see every once in a while,
we'll get a blue page.
Oops, not on that page.
But my header is going to be
either gray or blue depending
on how we hit it.
So that's cool.
That means I can test that
small change in an AB way
or in a Canary-type rollout.
And I can easily
get back from it
because it turns out that
my customers actually really
preferred the gray.
And I can just roll that back
with another quick change where
I set the 100% of my
traffic back to gray.
And I will never see that
blue abomination again.
So that's a quick example
of how you actually
use the routing capabilities.
Another thing that I want
to show you real quick,
though, is some
of the monitoring.
If we jump in, we have
full telemetry information
and tracing information.
And this is the
Jaeger UI, and it
shows you the requests that
have been coming through.
And I can actually drill
down into one of these
and see exactly
where all the time is
being spent, like
what's being called,
and how long it's taking.
So if I need to get information
about the actual operations
of what's going on,
I can very easily
figure out where I need
to make optimizations
or I need to make
changes to fix things.
The other thing I wanted
to show you is Grafana.
And if you look, we can
get a very detailed view
of the information
about the system,
of the memory, CPU, all
the information about that.
I can also show you a service
dashboard, front end service.
And it shows you request volume,
success rate, things like that.
So we have very detailed
information about what's
going on in the system.
And all this is just
absolutely built into Istio
and available at all
times and can be extended
as well various plug-ins.
So I'm going to hand this
back to Nanden, then.
NANDEN SRIDHAR: So
what you have seen now
is how to use Istio to do
basic service management.
Like, what you've
seen with service
management needs are the
basic ability to do mTLS.
So you can encrypt and
authenticate your traffic.
Second, you want to have
this operational agility
so you can do AB testing.
You can [INAUDIBLE]
releases, all of that.
And third, you want to
do policy enforcement.
That applies to all services.
And this is back to back.
So how does service
management really
tie in with API management?
So first, let us establish
what is API management,
and then let's talk about how
service management compares
with API management.
API management is the ability
to provide an API catalog
for discovery.
If you go back to this
architecture here--
this is the application
that Scott wrote--
it's got a currency service.
It's got a check out service.
Very frequently in
enterprises, the team
that built the
currency service is
different from the team that
built the check out service.
Now that teams that built
the currency service
will very frequently want
to have exposed that service
in some sort of a catalog that's
available in the enterprise.
And the team that built the
checkout service will refer
to the currency service's API
specification, potentially
request access to it.
And if access should be
granted by the team that
built the currency service,
they will grant that access,
and then we go
ahead and build it.
So while as a service to
service communication path,
none of this was visible, at
the development stages, when
these services were in fact
being shared between teams,
API management was
definitely needed.
So let's [INAUDIBLE] that.
If I'm just building services
that is only ever going
to be consumed from within
my team, then by all means,
something like a Java
doc or a readme file
is good enough to
share information
about how to consume
that other service.
But the minute you
want your service
to be available outside your
team into a consumable form,
then you want to have a
catalog to publish in.
The moment you have a catalog
where people can consume
your services, you want
to have the ability
to control who has access and
how they have access to it
and so on.
The next step is the ability
to view usage reporting.
You saw Scott show a
distributed tree which
said this is how
much latency is spent
in every single
microservice and so on.
But neither [? Grafana ?] nor
the [? Jaeger ?] UI showed
Scott who his top biggest five
applications are because Istio
does not have the view
of an application.
It has view of services,
and many services
form an application.
For example, your call
center application
isn't one big application, but
it is a bunch of microservices.
But if you want
that view of what
does it look like from an
application level, which
is a logical grouping
of microservices,
you want to have some
analytics being reported.
If you want to
productize your data
and expose it to others
for monetization purposes,
very likely you're not going
to productize individuals
microservices, but you're
going to productize
a logical grouping of
these microservices
and make it available
as a single API.
And lastly, of course, you
want to have the ability
to do documentation, try
your APIs, and so on.
Then there is the aspect
in an API gateway.
Within an API gateway,
I want the ability
to do transformations
and mediations.
I want the ability to do
proctoring and quotas.
I want set protection for
my JSON and XML payloads,
and I want some caching
optimization techniques
to be available.
These are certain
crosscutting systems
that you want in a
gateway so that again,
individual microservice
developers don't have to do it.
So keeping these
in mind, let's now
compare API management
and service management.
All APIs are services but
not all services are APIs.
Your caching service is a
service, but it's not an API.
Your website is a service,
but it's not an API.
But the invoicing
service is also
an API because I could
invoke it as an API.
So we think that Istio
and service management
is needed for all services.
Anything with at least a TCP
port can be managed by Istio.
That could be in your database.
That would mean your NoSQL
database, whatever that may be.
And when some of
those services need
to be exposed for consumption
outside of your team,
then it becomes an API, and
you need API management for it.
And that's how we try to look
at API management and service
management.
They are really
complementary functions.
Even if you drill down
into the features offered
by both of them, you'll notice
that although the features
section look similar, they
offer different perspectives.
API management of course
works on HTTP-based APIs,
but service management can
apply to a TCP-based service,
and that's perfectly fine.
When it comes to authorization
and authentication,
service management relies on
mutual TLS and the identity
in the Spiffe
certificate for identity
whereas API management can rely
on API keys and OAuth tokens
and not necessarily
at the nTLS level.
When you look at
monitoring, it's
really monitoring from a
production operations team
point of view.
It's a production ops person who
wants to know the distributed
trace to find bottlenecks.
Apigee's monitoring is more
from APIs provider point of view
where you're going
to try and take it
as to which application
that's consuming these
is causing the most errors,
who are my top 10 developers,
and you see how this [INAUDIBLE]
almost leads into analytics.
Rate limiting is
also very different.
A rate limiting for
service management
is more to do with I want
to protect my back end.
But a rate limiting from an
API management point of view
is from the consumer
point of view
to say I don't want
these consumers to exceed
their quota.
I want to create a gold tier.
I want to create
a platinum tier.
I want to create a
bronze tier and so on.
These are all consumer-specific.
They are not backend-specific.
Lastly, monetization and
portals are abilities
that come with APIs management.
You don't really
monetize services.
You monetize APIs.
So I hope you're drawing
this distinction of how
service management
and API management
are complementary features.
Service management is needed
for all your services.
And when some of those
services become APIs,
you use API management.
So how do we Apigee
integrate with Istio?
Assuming that you've
already got Istio
to do services management, then
how do we layer on top of this
to also do API management?
What you're seeing here
is the architecture
that we have for
services management.
It includes the side car.
It includes mixer and pilot,
and I have on purpose not
introduced Citadel here.
It's not relevant to this
current conversation.
But it could have been here.
So put service management here.
In my previous slide,
we talked about how
mixer is that
extensibility point
that you would have kept it.
Naturally, we would extend
mixer to add API management
capability.
In addition to
that, we introduced
two important concepts--
the concept of an API portal and
the concept of an API dashboard
to view the metrics.
And mixer becomes the
policy decision point
to do API key or
OAuth verification.
It's the point where you
do quota enforcement,
and it's also the place where
you collect analytics to send
it off to the dashboard.
The next point is how
does Apigee do it.
Well, naturally, we integrate
the mixer component of Istio
to talk to Apigee Edge or the
control plane in Apigee Edge
so that the Istio
mixer is Apigee aware.
And this is a very
critical point.
You have now, the integration
of mixer to Apigee edge,
you have now made Istio
Apigee API management aware.
Mixer is now able
to enforce the rules
that you define in Apigee.
So Apigee becomes a place
where you author entitlements.
Apigee becomes a place where
you publish your services
for your portal.
And those rules are
pulled down by mixer
and then enforced
in the service mesh.
So let's take this
with an actual example.
We have the retail site
Fazzio that [INAUDIBLE]..
And now [INAUDIBLE]
got a new requirement.
This new requirement
is the shipping service
needs to be exposed externally.
And that's the
requirement he had.
So far, the shipping
service was only
used by the checkout
service, and that was never
exposed outside, and it was
all done through the front end
application.
But now his requirement
is to actually expose
the shipping service as an API.
So Scott, tell us
how you do this.
SCOTT GANYO: OK.
Thanks, Nanden.
So what we're going
to do, first off,
is expose our new tracking API.
We have a service,
and we already
have a gateway that's exposing
the application itself.
But what we need down here
is to expose the tracking
and route it to our
shipping microservice
and allow access through that.
So once we apply this,
then we will have access.
It's configured.
We will have access into
this API as you can see here.
The next step that we're going
to look at is wiring up Apigee.
So we need to be able to apply
Apigee analytics to our Istio
routing or to our
Istio application,
and we also want to
apply authorization.
Right now, I'm going to
show you a little bit of how
that wiring happens.
The Apigee Analytics,
as you can see here,
this little CRD basically
tells the Istio mixer
which attributes in
Istio to send to Apigee.
And you can see we have requests
times and destination hosts
and things like that.
So this is the analytics part.
And we also have a
template for authorization
that tells mixer which parts of
the authorization, when it does
authorization, which
attributes from mixer
need to go to Apigee so
that we can do that as well.
And here you'll see
things like API key,
and you'll see claims from
OAuth and things like that.
So in both cases, we're
able to report on not just
the request itself but
who's making the request.
The next thing that
we'll do is apply a rule.
Now this is what actually tells
mixer that we want to send--
in this case,
we're going to send
all inbound requests
to the Apigee adapter
and thus to Apigee.
And this is for analytics.
So we'll take everything
that there is.
Configure that rule.
And now we can look at
the analytics reporting.
Now when you get into
Apigee analytics,
it gives you all kinds
of great information.
This, for example, shows by
device type, but you can also--
you can drill in on this
one to various services.
So we can look at the
product catalog service
and how it's being hit.
We can look at
error code analysis
and actually see if
we're getting errors.
And we're not getting many.
We can look at
developer engagement
is interesting once we
have a set of developers.
And we'll talk about that in
just a moment and then actually
API proxy performance as well.
So you can see all
the developers,
and you can be able
to sort them by email.
So you can see that.
OK, so-- and we have all
that coming into Apigee now.
But now we need to expose what
we're doing to the developers.
And we do that
through a product.
And when we create
an API product,
this is what actually gives us
the control over how the API is
accessed by developers.
So what you see here is I've
created a product called
tracking details,
and I've made it
publicly available to
any registered developer.
So once they've registered,
they can have access to this,
and it's automatic approval.
I set a quota.
So any developer can actually
only access this once or--
sorry, five times-- each minute.
I'm not setting any
OAuth scopes right now.
I set a path of
slash, which basically
means they have
access to anything,
any paths on this
particular product.
And then the interesting
part here is Istio services.
Now I've bound this to
this particular service
that I've already deployed
and that I opened up access
to a second ago.
And this is the
shipping service.
And this is the full
DNS name of the shipping
service in Kubernetes.
So having set all
that, let me save that.
And we come back, and
now we can register
to use that API in the portal.
So I come to the portal
and check out the APIs.
Oh, there's my API.
It's the tracking details.
And I've already exposed
this to the portal
with an open API definition
as you can see here.
If you look at this
open API definition,
we have a get tracking, and
you pass it a tracking number.
And the body of a
response is going
to have information such as the
carrier, the status, tracking
location, things like that.
And then you can see here we
also have the authentication
requirements, that it
requires either an API
key or a jwt_bearer token.
So right now, we don't
have it protected.
So we should be able to access
it with no additional work.
And there we go.
So we get a correct response.
Now that's great.
I can try the API.
But what I really want
to do is create an app
so that I can use the
API as a developer
because normally, you're
not going to have the AP
open to just anybody, right?
So what we're going to
do is protect the API
with an API key.
So now I've said that my
API is no longer public.
It has to be a
registered developer
because you have to have
an API key to access this.
And you'll notice that
we're saying it's any--
we're only doing it for
the shipping destination.
And that's so that our app can
continue working as normal,
the web app.
And this only affects that
shipping API or the shipping
service, in fact.
So let's go back to
the portal again.
Let's go here.
And now we should
see if we execute--
yes, we have a 403
permission denied.
Now we have to have an
API key to access it.
And we can do that
ourselves as well.
But what we have to do is we
create an account and sign in.
Now I've already
created an account.
So I'm going to log
in with my account.
And if we go here, you can see
that I don't have any apps.
Well, I have to create an app.
So I'm going to
call it my details.
Now once the app
is created, you'll
see that I have access or
I grant access to this API
and add an API key for the app.
Now this should be able
to be used directly
to try out that API.
So let's go back to this API.
So now we're going to
authorize this with the API key
that we just created.
And actually, let me
manually enter it.
I'll show you the key.
Authorize, and we get a 200
OK, and we're back in business.
Excellent.
So API key is working for us.
So now we need to
try this with OAuth.
First of all, we'll go ahead
and protect it with the OAuth.
And you can see here we have
an auth spec that tells it
we're using my issuer and
where I get the tokens
and where to retrieve
my certs from.
In this case, we'll go
ahead and apply that.
Now when we apply that, that
actually goes out to the proxy.
So it's actually
running on the envoy.
And envoy retrieves
that information
and can evaluate
that right there.
So let's go back to
the portal once again.
Then we'll try it with
the same authorization
that we have before.
And this time, we get origin
authentication failed.
It's a different error because
that's coming from the proxy.
So now what we need to
do is we need to go back,
and we have to get a token.
So to get the token, again,
go back into our app.
And we're going to need
the key and the secret.
So let me grab the key.
And I'm just going
to go ahead and put
these in here, the secret.
We'll put that in
here, evaluate that,
and then see if we can
create this token for us.
Here's the token
that it's created.
And this is the actual contents
of what that token looks like.
And you can see that we
have all the information
about the user in this.
So let's grab this
token and go ahead
and put it in the bare
header in this access.
And you can see now
we have access again.
And I'll turn this
back over to Nandan.
Thank you.
NANDEN SRIDHAR: What you see
now is the ability for us
to extend the Istio mixer
adaptor to apply API management
tools in a service mesh.
So service management
provides the value
of applying observability,
operational agility,
and security to
your microservices.
Apigee extends service
management in Istio
to give you the ability to have
a portal, to get API analytics,
and then to apply API management
rules within your service mesh
like quotas, API key
verification, OAuth,
and all those things
that you typically
associate with API management.
So I hope you guys
liked this talk.
I'm going to pause here and
see if there are any questions.
SPEAKER 1: Once again, thank
you for attending the webinar.
Before we get on to
the Q&A, a couple
of quick things,
and Apigee customers
can sign up for starting to
use the entire integration
with service mesh.
And then you have the
other links over there
with regards to
what is available.
You have resources which will
be made available to you.
They're available on
the resource console.
So those are your core hub.
You can go ahead and download
the [INAUDIBLE] documentation.
With that, I would like to
quickly get on to the questions
that we have.
We have a lot of
questions, and we'll
tap it out to two
questions that I believe--
Nandan, would you
want to take them up?
One is, is mixer
adaptor the only way
of integrating more with
Apigee and Istio currently?
NANDEN SRIDHAR: Yes,
within the [INAUDIBLE]
itself, that is the
point of extensibility
that mixer is
where we extend it.
But of course, our portal,
analytics, they all [INAUDIBLE]
off of mixer.
So you get those benefits just
through the mixer extension.
SPEAKER 1: Fantastic.
And I still have
one final question
because I got a lot of things
about this particular question.
That is with regard to
the 30 minute key rotation
that was offered by Istio.
Is there something
that's configurable?
Can you give us some
more information on that?
NANDEN SRIDHAR: Yes,
it is configurable.
30 minutes, I believe,
is the default.
But you can increase it.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Fantastic.
Unfortunately, we are
completely out of time.
We will not be able to
take any more questions.
But before we go, thank
you for your attendance.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you to all
of the speakers.
I want to call out
special attention
to the next webinar that's
coming up on September 26.
It's about the craft of
API product management.
It will be a great
session [INAUDIBLE]
talk to you about framework,
business models, and KPIs
that you as an API product
manager need to take note of.
We're also going to have some
experiential learning where
we have customers,
enterprises just like you,
who are going to share their
story as to how they've done.
Some of these experts
are going to provide
as to what kind of
lessons they've learned
and what other kind of
advice they can provide.
So please feel free to
register for the webinar
as we look forward to
learning along with you.
With that said, I think
we're completely out of time.
Thank you.
We really appreciate
your time today.
Have a wonderful
rest of your day.
Thank you.